[MUSIC PLAYING]
ZACHARY SENZER: Hey, everyone.
I'm so glad that you can
make it today to our session,
and I hope that you're having
a really awesome Google I/O.
My name is Zachary Senzer,
and I am a product manager
on the Actions on Google
and Google Assistant teams.
BARRIE LEVINSON: And
I'm Barrie, and I'm
a program manager for Google
Assistant focused on discovery.
We really want people
to find your content
and use it on Google Assistant.
And today, we're here to talk
about how your content can
reach millions of devices
on Google Assistant
really without much
work at all for you.
So by day two of I/O, this
may be a refresher, but just
a quick overview of
the opportunity that
presents itself to you
with Google Assistant.
Assistant really helps
people get things done
with over one million Actions.
Actions is the word that
we use to describe things
that Assistant can do.
And Assistant is
ready to help wherever
users are with over 500
million voice-activated devices
like Google Home,
eligible mobile phones,
and other devices with screens
where Google Assistant works.
Assistant's available across the
globe in more than 25 locales
and by the end of this year, in
80 countries and 30 languages.
So that's a lot of devices
and a lot of Actions
that Assistant can do and
a lot of potential users
for your content.
So how can you bring your site's
content into this ecosystem?
Google's presented ways for you
to optimize content for Search
since what my kids
would call the 1900's.
For sites with content in
popular areas like news,
podcasts, and recipes,
the same kinds
of optimizations that you have
likely made already for Search
will also help your
content become discoverable
in Google Assistant.
So we'll be explaining how
to use structured data in AMP
in your content to
help drive traffic
to your site for both
Assistant and for Search
at the same time with the
same work on your part.
So our research shows that
users are accessing information
in new ways with different
kinds of use cases
throughout the day.
We know that users are
accessing media and news
content in their morning and
in their commute routines.
And then in the evening
around meal preparation,
recipe content
becomes interesting.
Google's put a lot
of thought into how
to be there for the
user throughout the day
in these different
kinds of use cases.
So as a user, I can
be in conversation
with Google Assistant
throughout the day
to get things done in my world.
Let's take, for example, Zach
at the center of his world.
Let's say Zach missed
the latest episode
of his favorite podcast.
He can just ask his
Assistant to play it.
Or if he's not sure what
he wants to listen to,
he can explore a
different podcast to try.
At dinner time, when
Zach is hungry for ideas
and isn't sure what to make, he
asks his Assistant for recipes.
Assistant on mobile
presents a carousel
of recipes that are easy
to browse and load quickly.
And with a single tap, he can
choose a Food Network recipe
to send straight
to his Google Home
so Zach doesn't have
to worry about handling
his phone in the kitchen
when he might be busy
using his hands to
cook whatever it
is that he's making for dinner.
And Google Assistant is
there throughout the day
to help with lots
of other use cases
too, like reading the
news, translations, getting
directions, sorting
through photos, and more.
So let's have a look at how
some providers are getting
content to users like Zach and
many others throughout the day.
Here are three examples.
So structured data markup can
produce carousels and rich
results in Google Assistant.
By asking a voice-activated
device to hear the news,
or listen to a podcast,
or find a recipe,
a user is connected
to content right away.
On the left, a user is asking
for top stories in business
and right away gets a carousel
of the latest headlines
rendered quickly
with nice imagery
from the source site of
"The New York Times."
In the middle, a
user is asking for
and gets recipes
from Food Network--
easy to browse and select
a recipe to send straight
to Google Home.
And then on the
right, another user
asks her Google Assistant
to play "Planet Money."
And immediately, she starts
hearing the latest episode
from NPR.
So this is the
Actions directory.
You might know that the
Actions directory has
a listing for each
and every Action
that users can do on Assistant.
When recipe, podcast, and news
providers optimize your content
using structured
data, you become
eligible for an auto-generated
page listed in the Actions
directory.
The Actions directory is
organized both by category,
like food and drink, and
it's also organized by things
that users are trying to
do, like find food recipes
or play a podcast.
So that means that your
Action, your content
could be presented in multiple
places in the directory
depending on what
users are trying to do.
We built the Actions
directory to be
accessible with a single
tap from Google Assistant,
like you see here on mobile.
And there's also a version for
web available on the desktop
and also for mobile browsers.
And each page is shareable.
So you could
promote your Action,
or your current users could
share it with their friends
or with their followers.
So there are three
things that you
can choose to do to get
your content best integrated
with Assistant.
Structured data in AMP
are key to optimizing
for Search and for Assistant
with the same work to do both.
When you invest in
structured data,
you enable more
discovery on more devices
and help users get things
done throughout their day.
Also, implementing best
practices with structured data
can make your content eligible
for carousels and rich results
like you just saw and for a
page on the Actions directory.
When you further enhance
your content using AMP,
it helps your mobile pages
to load quickly and take
advantage of Google AMP cache.
We'll also talk
about how you can
take things further and
claim your Actions directory
page to make it your
own and participate
in additional features,
like user reviews.
And you can consider
going further
to build your own custom Action
using the Actions on Google
Developer platform.
We'll cover all
three in the talk.
So I've mentioned
structured data
markup up in AMP a few times
already, and let's just
make sure we're all on
the same page about that.
AMP stands for
Accelerated Mobile Pages,
and the AMP icon is
an indication to users
that this mobile page will
load quickly and smoothly.
When a user selects
an AMP mobile page,
Search retrieves it
from Google AMP cache,
which enables a variety
of load optimizations.
Google uses
structured data markup
on the web to best understand
the content on each
and every page.
Structured data markup
is a standardized format
for specifying information
about a page and classifying it.
So if I have a recipe page, what
are the ingredients, the cook
time, nutrition
information, and so on.
You help Google
Search understand
content on your pages by
giving explicit clues that
come when you conform to the
standards with structured data
markup.
There are really well-documented
standards for structured data
that vary by content
type, and the standards
are consistent with open
standards for schema.org.
So we're going to look at
examples for news, podcasts,
and recipes today.
There are a few different ways
to specify your structured data
for web pages.
JSON-LD, or JavaScript Open
Notation with Linked Data,
is encoding that's used by
Google's Knowledge Graph.
JSON-LD shows up like
a big blob of code
near the head of each page.
And it starts with a script
tag that says, hey, browser.
Calling the JavaScript
that contains some JSON-LD.
So this really simple
snippet of markup
says, this is a WebSite type.
I'm using the vocabulary
from schema.org.
And the website has this URL.
Another implementation
of markup would
be with HTML extensions that
places different syntaxes
throughout the page
with tagged attributes
that name the
properties and expose
the structured data in both the
head and the body of the pages.
But we're going to focus on
JSON-LD as a preferred method
to use wherever possible.
And you can also use
Google's examples
to create your
JSON-LD markup rather
than starting from scratch.
So in order to
bring this to life,
we're going to use a case study
example of a family recipe
site.
Structured data markup in AMP
works for large publishers,
like Food Network or "The New
York Times," as you've seen.
And it also works for anyone,
including a small family recipe
site.
And in fact, this is not just
any small family recipe site.
This is my own
family's recipe site.
Recently, my husband and I
optimized our existing family
recipe site using structured
data markup in AMP.
So there are a few
characters in the story
so you can follow along the
plot that I'll introduce first.
First, the stroopwafel.
You might know
that a stroopwafel
is a Dutch cookie with some
caramel inside of some waffles.
And it'll show up in pictures.
And then Sander's
Dutch stroopwafels--
Sander is my 12-year-old son.
And Coert Vonk is the site
owner, and he's my husband.
And he's also Dutch.
So our site features a lot
of Dutch family recipes,
like the ones that you
see here in the carousel,
including Sander's
Dutch stroopwafels.
This rich carousel of search
results from our recipe site
appears when you ask Google
Assistant "find recipes
from Coert Vonk."
And then you can choose one and
send it to your Google Home.
So here's the before and
after with our recipe site.
Before we made the changes
for structured data,
a page like on the
left would show up
in Search for a specific
query, like "Sander's
Dutch stroopwafel recipe."
You can see there's a
pretty ordinary search
result with a blue link
and some unremarkable text.
After we optimized it
with structured data--
on the other side--
we started to participate in
rich results and carousels
for the same query.
And you can spot a
few more differences.
Because of structured
data markup,
Search is so much
smarter about the data
that it finds on our
site and on this page.
The generic blue link is gone.
You can see a row of chips
to select relevant content
under the title "Recipes."
Search better understands our
recipe content, of course,
from the way the data
is passed in the markup.
With structured data
markup for recipes,
we were able to
increase discovery
for Search and for Google
Assistant at the same time
with exactly the same work.
And true story, at the end
of April, we got an email--
so it's like last week--
from Google Assistant saying
that our site traffic,
although still pretty small,
had increased more than 300%
in the month of April with
72% of user acquisition coming
through organic search.
So after our site was indexed
and successfully converted
to structured data, we noticed
a page in the Actions directory.
Earlier, you saw the
Actions directory page
for Food Network.
And this is the
Actions directory
page for our family site
rendered on web browser,
or a desktop.
The other one was
obviously on mobile.
Later on, we'll see how
this page can be claimed.
And we can go on to customize
it with our own images
and information.
So for a closer look
at what it takes
to use structured data markup
in AMP, let's look at the code.
And we'll continue to
use the family recipe
site as an example.
So first, the generic JSON-LD
structured data snippet
for type Recipe.
In addition to the general
structured data guidelines,
you'll need to follow
the specific guidelines
for the structured data
type that you have in order
to be eligible in
rich results displays
in both Search and Assistant.
So most Search structured data
uses open standard schema.org
vocabulary, as I've mentioned.
Although, what Google
Search might require
could differ a little bit as
what's required by schema.org.
So Google is able
to read JSON-LD data
when it's dynamically injected
into a page's contents.
And that's what we're doing
in the family recipe site
architecture.
Here, the server-side PHP helps
generate an AMP recipe page
with markup using recipe data
details that are pulled out
of the MySQL database.
When a recipe page is
requested by the web browser,
PHP responds by consulting
the database for the recipe
details, then marks
it up as HTML,
and returns the
dynamic page results.
This also inserts
the structured data
we added as JSON-LD inside the
script in the page in its head.
So the highlighted
part on the slide
is the essence of what
is new after optimizing
with the structured data markup.
Obviously, for a
recipe collection,
the type of structured data
we used was the recipe's type.
So let's have a
closer look at that.
This is the first
section of markup
for the page
recipe, specifically
Sander's Dutch stroopwafels.
Each page carries markup
that's specific to it.
So we see the result
of where the recipe
information from the database
is pulled to generate markup.
Going down the
page, you can easily
parse the resulting markup
and see the name, description,
author, recipe yield,
prep time, and cook time.
The format is always expressed
as a set of attribute value
pairs.
So name-- Sander's
Dutch stroopwafels.
You use recipe property
markup for a single recipe
at a time, not a category
of recipes or a whole list.
And there are 15 total
recipe properties
that are recommended, although
only name is actually required.
Going into this, we didn't
have an image for every recipe
in the collection.
So that's something
we're working on.
But you can see the highlighted
URL is the block of markup
for a photo that would
be for the big stack
of gooey stroopwafels.
So continuing the markup
for the same recipe page,
we have ratings.
Inspired by structured
data, we added ratings
to the site, which
isn't something
that had been a feature before.
You can see here the
markup for ratings
that includes data
for the rating value,
a count of reviews, and the best
and worst rating for the recipe
page.
And now on the right,
you can see how ratings
will render in search results.
And this is the direct result
of adding the structured data
markup for ratings on the page.
You see the stars in
the rating, et cetera.
And now the last
part of the markup--
still for the same recipe--
shows the rest of the format
truncated a little bit
to fit on the slide.
Here, we tagged the
recipe ingredients
and pull the recipe
instructions.
And finally, the
nutrition information.
So for us, nutrition
information was
something we had
in the database,
but many of the
fields were empty.
And so adding more data has
been a good enhancement here.
And then at the end, you
see we close the script.
And now you've seen the full
format for structured data
for the type Recipe.
The Structured Data
Testing Tool helps
you to format your data correct
to standards for whatever type
you're using.
Structured Data Testing
Tool is really easy to use.
It's open.
You can find it easily
on Google Search.
And so running the page
URL through the tool
shows any anomalies as
compared to the standards
for the type that I'm testing.
So you can see here that I
have an error where the cook
time was formatted in some
way that I might just type it
as a person as compared
to the ISO format
that structured data requires.
It's easy to go through and
fix errors one at a time.
And it would be recommended
to do this really
after just you have a few
pages to check the format.
So to summarize, our family
recipe site optimization
process with structured data--
we followed the
structured data guidelines
to create the markup
using JSON-LD.
And remember, you can follow
well-documented examples rather
than starting from scratch.
We then validate our code using
the Structured Data Testing
Tool, which is probably going
to be an iterative process where
you find and fix errors.
Make sure to unblock robots.txt,
noindex, or any access
controls which might keep
the crawlers from getting
to your markup.
And you're going to fix and
monitor errors and re-index
the site as you change it.
So there are a few
things that are
special about using structured
data markup in AMP to optimize
for news content.
Let's have a look.
There's a special
type, NewsArticle,
with just two properties
that are recommended
in the case of non-AMP pages.
The headline and the
image is highlighted.
For NewsArticles, when
you are optimizing
with AMP mobile pages,
additional properties
are required.
And those include the
publisher name, the logo, URL,
date published, date modified--
here and on the next slide.
AMP pages that have
structured data
can appear in a carousel
of stories, like the ones
that you saw from "The
New York Times" earlier.
Without the structured data,
AMP pages can load fast,
but they won't have
that formatting.
They would show up as standard
blue links in Search results.
Also for news content, if you
offer subscription-based access
to your website or if users
need to register for access,
there's a guideline that's
specific to implementing
structured data for subscription
and pay-walled content.
If your site is marked up
with structured data in AMP,
following the standards
for the type NewsArticle,
and also follows the Google
News index guidelines,
you could apply to be
included in Google News.
So now I'm going
to hand it to Zach
to talk to you about how to
leverage structured data markup
for your podcast content.
ZACHARY SENZER: All right.
So let's walk
through an example.
This is how NPR'S
"Planet Money" podcast
appears in the Actions
directory and Google
Search, which was all generated
with some simple markup.
By structuring your
podcast content,
you can enable your
podcast to appear in Google
Search results along
with individual episode
descriptions and even
an embedded player
for each episode.
Additionally, your content
may be automatically turned
into an Action on the Google
Assistant with a dedicated
page in the Actions directory.
In order for your podcast
to be properly indexed,
you'll need to first expose a
valid RSS feed that conforms
to RSS 2.0 specifications.
Second, ensure that your feed
has at least one episode.
And third, have a dedicated
home page for your podcast
that points to your RSS feed.
We'll now cover the essential
podcast level, episode level,
and home page
markup requirements
to make sure that your
content is set up for success.
This code shows the
podcast level tags
that need to get configured
for your podcast's RSS feed.
This example takes us to the
markup for NPR'S "Planet Money"
podcast.
First, make sure that
you have a tag that
defines your podcast title.
Here, this is "Planet Money."
The only two other
requirements are
tags that define your
podcast home page along
with episode tags,
which we'll cover next.
Optionally, you
can also add tags
that state the author,
description, image, category,
and language for your podcast.
These are the episode-level
tags in your podcast's RSS feed
that would then need
to get configured.
The only two requirements
here are the title
of the episode and
an enclosure tag,
which points to the URL of
the episode's audio file.
Optionally, you
can also configure
a description, publication
date, duration,
and more for each episode.
The last step is to make
sure that your podcast has
a home page that very
clearly describes
what the podcast is about.
NPR'S page for "Planet
Money" is shown here.
Make sure that this page
has a link that points
to your podcast's RSS URL.
And then once that's all
set up, you're on your way
towards being optimized for
both Google Search and Google
Assistant just by
configuring a few RSS tags.
So we just reviewed
structured data markup.
Now, the next big opportunity
is to then claim your page.
Claiming your Action will
unlock three key capabilities
for you--
first, the ability to modify
your directory listing;
second, the ability to view
analytics on your Actions
performance; and then third,
the opportunity for improved
ranking and discovery.
Here's the directory page that
was created for Barrie's recipe
content using structured markup.
Once a directory page is
created for your content,
you'll be able to
claim the Action simply
by creating a project
on the Actions
on Google Developer
Console, which
is the hub for creating,
managing, and optimizing
your Actions.
Shown here, the Actions on
Google Developer Console
is the place where you'll be
able to manage your Actions
after you claim them.
Once you claim, you'll
notice that there
is a dedicated section for
you to modify your directory
information.
You can use the Console
to change up your images
and descriptions to
more accurately reflect
your Actions and its content.
Additionally, once your
Actions are claimed,
you'll even be able to view
these analytics in the Console.
The Console can help
you to quickly monitor
your Action's star ratings over
time along with directory page
views.
For claimed Actions, users
will have the ability to rate
and submit written
reviews for your content.
This is all accessed using
the Actions directory.
So, for example, this is
how ratings and reviews
will appear on the directory
page for Barrie's recipe
content.
User reviews are one of
many quality indicators
that are used to impact ranking.
Most importantly, though,
ratings and reviews
are benchmarks that
users depend on when
looking for authentic
and relevant feedback.
All of this functionality
is accessible simply
by using structured data markup.
Now that we just covered
claiming your Action,
let's discuss by how creating
a custom conversational
Action you can take
advantage of the best
that both Actions on Google
and the Google Assistant
have to offer.
So you can either use markup
to optimize your existing
content for a more
assistive experience,
or you can decide to build
custom Actions with a much more
conversational and AI focus.
To take full advantage
of the Google Assistant,
the best path is to build a
custom conversational Action.
We'll now discuss the
thought process, rationale,
and overview of creating
these custom Actions.
To start, you will
most likely need
to revisit your
content's identity
for the AI-first world.
Your Action will need
more than just graphics.
It will need a fully
developed personality.
So, for example, is your
content funny or serious?
What voice will
represent your content?
And how can you
tailor the personality
of your Action to stand out in
a conversational environment?
Users are not just looking
to access your website
in an audio form.
The more rich your
conversational interaction,
the more we can then
suggest your Action
to increase discovery.
The Assistant learns from the
directory and other information
about which Actions may
be best for assisting
the user with their needs.
So rather than needing to
include your brand's name,
your content may be
recommended to the user.
Our goal is to
recommend Actions that
provide users with a really
high-quality end-user
experience.
And the best way to
create this more tailored,
branded experience is to visit
the Actions on Google Developer
Console and create a
custom Action from scratch.
Many providers, both
large and small,
have elected to go the
custom Action route.
We've been working with
partners like Food Network
to enhance their user
experience with custom Actions.
So as you see here, Food
Network's custom Action
is being triggered.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Hi, I
can help you find recipes
by name, ingredient, or chef.
What would you like?
ZACHARY SENZER: What's on now?
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Right
now on Food Network,
we've just started an episode
of "The Pioneer Woman."
"Diners, Drive-Ins and Dives" is
coming up at 11:00 AM Pacific.
You can ask for episode
details or for recipes.
Which would you like?
ZACHARY SENZER: How about
some episode recipes?
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Recipes
from "The Pioneer Woman,"
the middles.
ZACHARY SENZER: The first one.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT:
Bow-tie skillet Alfredo.
ZACHARY SENZER: Email
it to me for later.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: OK.
I've just sent this recipe
to your email address.
"Dee-lish."
What else can I help you with?
ZACHARY SENZER: Food Network's
custom conversational Action,
which you just experienced,
helps users find inspiration
in the kitchen across
devices with both displays
and eyes-free surfaces
such as Google Home.
Not only can users find recipes
from their favorite chefs
and shows, but they can
also send recipes via email
and see upcoming show times.
Food Network optimizes
their content
for the conversational world and
creates several opportunities
for reengagement.
First, users can ask when
their show is on air.
Then, they can ask for
the recipe currently being
prepared on the show.
And then finally,
they'll have the ability
to share the recipe outside
of Assistant to enjoy later.
In natural language,
all elements
of a conversational
flow are usually
woven together in a coherent
thread that includes context.
Food Network helps guide
users to relevant information
and anticipates their behavior.
This is the new Actions on
Google Developer Console, which
makes it easier than
ever to create custom
Actions for your content.
When you create a
project, you can
choose from several categories
that will tailor your workflow.
So whether you're a
podcast provider trying
to allow new users to
discover your content
or a news provider attempting
to reengage with your followers,
the Actions on Google
Developer Console
is the place to get started.
The Console's
workflow glides you
through the different
stages of development.
First, set up some
initial information
about how you would
like to be discovered.
Build Actions that
will help users
get things done
with the information
that they both want and need.
Then test your Actions,
either on devices
or by using our
new web simulator
to run through user flows.
Then deploy your Actions
either to production
or to limited alpha
and beta audiences.
Then finally,
measure the success
of your Actions with additional
rich analytics on usage,
errors, and discovery channels.
It's as simple as set up, build,
test, deploy, and measure.
There are numerous
surfaces that you
could target with
your custom Actions,
including those
with audio output
and those with screen output.
Building custom
Actions will allow
you to tailor the experience
based on the device being used.
For devices with screens,
including phones, televisions,
or smart displays, you can craft
special responses that really
take advantage of the screen.
If you're a podcast
provider, consider
showing video clips
and images that
can play alongside the audio.
News and recipe providers
can render rich graphics
to add even more meaning
to a story or recipe.
However, don't forget
to also optimize
for the eyes and
hands-free experiences
that speakers have to offer.
Whether it's getting
ready in the morning
or running out the door to
commute to and from work,
users won't always
have the ability
to interact with the display.
Users won't have the
time to browse a website
for information if they need
to keep their eyes on something
else or if their hands are full.
These are critical opportunities
throughout a user's day
that you'll be able to present
some really key information,
such as news stories
or a brand-new episode
of your podcast, for example.
We built the Assistant
leveraging the latest advances
in machine learning, AI, and
natural language processing
along with Google's
technology stack
to create a really advanced
assistive experience.
And you too can
leverage this power
while creating your Actions
in a multitude of ways.
To start, Actions are full
of endless opportunities.
You can use our
vast array of cards
to display substantial
onscreen information
in the form of text, hyperlinks,
and images for your content.
You can also leverage speech
synthesis markup language,
or SSML, to make your
responses even more lifelike.
Then, play around
with our brand theme
customizations to control your
content's visual appearance,
especially in some of our
beautiful new smart displays.
So here's an example of what
Barrie's custom Action could
look like running
on a smart display
by leveraging theme
customizations that
were configured in the Actions
on Google Developer console.
This is an awesome
opportunity for Barrie
to show off a nice big
photo of stroopwafels
along with a link
to the full recipe
to truly help her
content stand out.
Actions are personal.
Custom conversational
Actions allow
you to use Google Assistant's
location and context
awareness alongside account
linking and user storage
to tailor your experiences
for individual users
of your Actions.
If you're a content provider,
the Google Assistant
presents a special
opportunity for you
to interact with your users.
The signed-in
nature of Assistant
will allow you to provide
personalized podcast, recipe,
and news story recommendations.
You can also use the Assistant
to augment the content
consumption experience.
For podcast providers, you can
give additional information
about guests and stories being
discussed on a given episode.
If you're a news provider,
use Google Assistant
to help guide users
and provide them
with augmenting information
about people and places being
discussed along with
relevant recommendations,
such as articles
and news stories.
Barrie can also
leverage personalization
for the custom Actions
for her recipe content.
So there might be
conversations that
would benefit from knowing
a user's name or location.
Suppose Barrie wants
to suggest to her users
where they can find and purchase
ingredients and supplies
for a recipe.
She can also suggest
common ingredients
that might appear in a recipe
or pairing drinks and sides that
would go well with a recipe.
Barrie could then
use localization
to provide recipes to her users
in a wide variety of languages.
Actions are reengaging.
With custom
conversational Actions,
you can use Action
links to share
a URL that will deep link users
directly into your Action.
For your content, you can
also implement our updates API
to inform users about
upcoming shows, stories,
and special events using
push notifications.
The updates API can also allow
Barrie to send daily recipe
recommendations to her users.
Custom conversational Actions
are even transactional.
By taking advantage
of our transactions
API along with account linking,
you can leverage transactions
to allow users to
seamlessly purchase
premium content, merchandise,
and other physical or digital
goods.
This was just an overview
of the few of the things
that you could do by
creating custom Actions,
and there is much, much more.
Even when you're
at best, there's
always room to grow with
custom conversational Actions.
In conclusion,
structured markup in AMP
allows you to take your
existing web content
and optimize it for both Google
Search and Google Assistant.
You will also be eligible for
having a page in the Actions
directory.
In fact, many of
you have already
completed the necessary
markup for your content.
If so, you'll notice
that there is already
a page in the directory for
you to then claim your Action.
Claiming will allow you to
modify your directory listing,
view analytics, and
receive ratings and written
reviews for your content.
However, to go above and beyond
the limitations of markup,
visit the Actions on
Google Developer Console
to create a custom
conversational Action.
Doing so will allow you to use
many exciting personalization,
reengagement, and transactional
features and APIs as you
build out your custom Actions.
The opportunities for what you
can create for your content
are truly endless.
We cannot wait to see what
you can build with custom
conversational Actions to
leverage the full power of both
Actions on Google and
the Google Assistant.
And if you haven't
done so already,
you've also seen how to get
started with structured data
markup and reach Google
Assistant users looking
for answers and
help getting things
done throughout their day.
To see some really
awesome demos,
go ahead and check out
our Assistant Sandbox
and attend our office hours
to have one-on-one assistance
with any of your questions.
Thank you, and we
hope you all continue
to have a really
great Google I/O.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]